hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil 3 now
biggie is somewhere in this place but
Jill's back up on her feet so I think
everything is going to be ok
you saved my life I sure as [ __ ] didn't
that was all Carlos he carried you here
any treated you himself crazy bastard
where is he underground barrage
stockpile the vaccine enough to give
this city some hope he thinks he can do
this by yourself I'm going after him
wait did you see the broadcast they're
gonna blow the city sky-high I'm trying
to get a hold of someone anyone with the
clearance to stop it leave this mess to
him he's a professional so am I so yeah
that's what I was gonna say I was gonna
say that good yeah guess I'm not talking
you out of this no storage facilities
underground beneath this hospital I've
lost contact with Carlos sorry one
second I know you were talking but just
one second here do not discard that
don't you freaking dare Trump yeah who's
Carlos biggie you talking about biggie
the biggest TVs don't mind as I break
all these boxes I'm a kleptomaniac hope
you don't know something me and biggie
have in common
I didn't leave a goddamn thing for me
nope not a thing alright whatever your
name is is that a zombie bite on your
own by the way or I think we're just
gonna conveniently ignore that yeah
alright any zombies left - hello good
thing
good old biggie was so thorough with all
of these Zombo knees apparently and now
I can unlock the things of which I was
hoping to unlock hello good job Oh mo mi
is about to get a mag good me think me a
made me get mag boom oh hi bud this
looks like Nikolai's work ah Nikolai
what is that scrublord doing over here
also stupid biggie not picking up the
explosives like a scrub speaking of
which maybe I should have taken out
maybe it is horrifically negligent of me
not to have that yeah probably not a
good idea now have that and yet here I
go I just for some reason will not stoop
to the level of using a Grenada Luger
oh I should have used the grenouille
Luger okay it's you and me but why is
this not burst fire nope
missed me beats Wow nope when you corner
me like that it's kind of hard to dodge
Wow nope okay you know what
we're going like this we're doing this I
bet I can do this I bet if I have this
equipped it's gonna yes yes yes baby
Oh with dance oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there we
go
oh [ __ ] we're dancin we're dancin what
dancing you will meet with dance well go
dance miss me wow that was a really
ineffective dodge Oh
[Music]
oh come on give me a stab [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what I thought
[ __ ] oh I didn't grab any health item
I was I was doing that without health
item just because I didn't care if I
died I wanted to be a learning
experience but I got him oh yeah oh man
that is so sad for you Oh more grenade
launcher stuff I it would be really
smart if I had that wouldn't it be but
alas I don't that's the unfortunate
thing is I just don't it's so weird oh
well I got my knife and that's all that
really matters
I like the dodge mechanic the dodge
mechanic adds a bit of depth to it and
it allows for situations like that so
now I can understand why they made the
knife unlimited use because that does
give it a bit more flexibility in terms
of being able to do things that I would
want to do you know what me mean you
know what me mean now if only like the
zombie attacks could also be dodged like
that because it goes through like this
scripted moment whenever a zombie comes
your way that's like oh I'm gonna get
you and then you gotta click the button
to fight off but in the end it doesn't
seem to actually matter be able to dodge
er I'm gonna go back to the safe room in
here grab some medical supplies maybe
maybe debate getting the grenade
launcher I can put away the shotgun
because I don't have any ammo for it
right now I'm still not in the mood to
combine any of explosives so I'll just
keep the explosive rounds I do not have
any grenades which is negligent that
made sense sure I've got lots of mine
rounds don't really have a use for them
but
what can you do what can you do
obviously I can do nothing about that
nothing I could do
let me put that away because I don't
have the mag yet the Magnum I mean I
don't have the Magnum numb and if I
don't have the mag num-num how am I
gonna be able to use the Magnum ammo so
I need to procedurally go through this
back track on the things that I
definitely need to open like here
there's a locker in here you better not
get up this time
Oh what did I just say oh I just got
cured I just did there we go
stay down stay down stay down stay down
stay down stay down
ah you guys did not stay down there we
go
you guys stay down this time you stay
down all right that's what's good for
you so you better do it i double-checked
all of you guys but biggie just never
follows through biggie is not the most
thorough of the bunch shotgun shells hey
stop dillweed dick hole that's
everything in here there should be
anything any other place Wow miss me
that's what you get I probably don't
need to shoot all those guys I probably
run in there lock picked in and gotten
out but it felt satisfying to do so at
the end of the day like that's that's
really nice that's really nice I'm gonna
put that away for now just because I
will get the shotgun when I need it but
for now there's something in the
sickroom probably another explosive or
something like that I'm not gonna waste
s placebo on the fodder here
why are you grimacing
I DEP whoa what no what whoa what I did
not open that was her code hidden
somewhere in this facility oh I feel
like I missed out oh well whatever it's
not a huge loss [ __ ] happens
and it usually happens to me so what can
you do ooh damn son where'd you find
that good no good no I'm not gonna trust
the mag I even remember back when I had
the mag in Resident Evil 2 Magnum sorry
I didn't use it that much just because
it was very powerful yes but if I missed
like and you know I don't trust my shots
that well if I missed it was just game
over so you know it kind of has it sit
on that one I bet it's somewhere written
on like the walls in the environment the
code for the safe there and I missed
damn shame damn shame
mag ammo perfect that'd be great if I
actually have a magnum you're dead you
dead you chumps want to dance said there
was something in here it's got to be
like MOS placebo is this looks evil all
right
thank you very much for your
contribution to me I think I've gotten
everything now I just need to figure out
a way to get over go through here maybe
I can crawl maybe Jill I think I can
squeeze by yeah you can squeeze by
squeezed by squeezed by all right
perfect
nice nice oh good dirty shoes on the
I'm glad no one wanted to jump down
there without shoes on oh no that's sad
all right yeah but you ignore the broken
glass land straight on your knees who
needs it nah I do well would you look at
that if it isn't the Magnum yeah
guaranteed to give you a headache and
guaranteed to give someone else a
headache that's probably the joke you
made I'm not really being original here
am I just pretend like I said something
clever please ooh there we go what's
over there
that's where I need to go is how do I
get over there this is it's not through
reception definitely not was it is it
just the reception did I only go through
to get supplies or was there something
else that might have just been this big
supply run I didn't I literally didn't
get anything that was like requisite to
go oh hey hey oh you wanna dance Wow
miss me [ __ ]
yeah okay so I gotta be I gotta be
closer on the Dodgers to get that
special moment Oh God
look even not that close a little
smaller room in here oh yeah there we go
what we call perfect timing baby whoa oh
that's what we call perfect timing baby
Oh God Oh backhand didn't expect I don't
have anything let's go mano-a-mano come
on you think I'm in danger
big G I did it no my need is very
unhealthy don't mind me no my meat don't
I mean don't mind me whoa good thing I
got all these saved up I mean it's very
stupid of me to do that but hey pretty
cool though right
Brittany Torino weak no I'm gonna keep
one of these on me so I don't have to
run back I'm gonna put away the mag for
now put away the shotgun shells just try
to do it with this I will come back if I
need additional lies but for now I'm
pretty okay okay through here is this
open now
oh it's been open the whole I could have
picked it in any then where did that
where's the tip big t did you see a big
monster run by you and you didn't think
to do anything to stop it
they're just like Joel Jill's got that
okay thank you thank you big T thank you
thank you
thank you big t
just so helpful this looks grimy now boo
this looks like the environment I ran
out of to get to away from the mr. X in
Resident Evil 200 those are big trucks
are we absolutely sure that I want to go
underground
are we completely and utterly sure that
I want to go underground also very
convenient that the weight underground
to where we needed to go was right in
the hospital a little strange but very
convenient don't know what's in there
and I don't think I want to hey this
looks familiar
let's go baby let's go
[Music]
that is a lot of supply trucks going
through or whatever the hell's that's my
question that is my question right now
and right here that is definitely my
question I'll get to you in a second
they see something over here yeah
definitely my question
I definitely wonder that myself I'm sure
that people did but they were silenced
with where they were able to actually
raise any stink about it which is how
this usually goes and then everyone's is
trying to go about their day trying to
get their jobs done trying to pay their
bills so that they don't try any further
I get it wonder if you could beat the
game with the knife now that would be
ballsy that would be very very ballsy I
wonder cuz they did put in the mechanic
where you if you get a good dodge and
you have your knife out you can stab
them I wonder is there an achievement
for beating the game with just a knife
is it even possible no my lockpick is
done we've identified an issue with the
electrical box where the concurrent use
of heavy machinery overloads and causes
the fuses to blow if you encounter this
problem and can't get the elevator
running please stay calm gather fuses
from the sub generators situated around
the warehouse and use those to restore
power to the main generator as quickly
as possible
man you're putting a lot of electrical
engineering on your random employees
although if they're stuck in the
elevator
put that away put that away put this
over here what am I gonna do with all
this inventory space well nothing
apparently up nothing don't need nothing
what do we need nothing yeah we don't
need nothing what are we talking about
we don't need a damn thing we don't need
a goddamn thing we're good to go we're
all set we're squared away we've got it
should lock door huh all right then
peek-a-boo I see you
oh I said Nikola Nick Nick it's me
Nick your friend Jill Nick Nick almost
miss this explosive I would have been I
would have been a trip huh Nick Oh what
was that guy
that's gross gross Nick Nick Nick Nick
Nikolai
all right fine what's under here oh he's
not he's not gonna wait for me there
Yeah right oh I guess I gotta go say hi
to you alive nope you alive
I guess it's problematic to call a
zombie alive sir Undead technically you
French for Russian what are you what are
you what are you okay so I need Foos A's
I remember something about this oh good
you alive
yes catch it catch it catch it
Oh God and say your ball sack Oh God Oh
is horrible I don't like you I do not
like you I also don't know why you're
puffing ashes whenever I try to stab you
oh this is horrible I hate you let me
stab your legs who knew your legs were
your one weakness combined with your
ball sack you'll no one will ever oh I
miss me
Oh God don't get up
oh that's the worst thing you could do
oh don't get up I'm a mutant [ __ ]
now you're back down alright you know
what just I don't like you at all
oh no no thank you no thank you
no no you don't Oh he's not dying is he
healing oh he's healing damage oh he is
definitely healing damaged yeah maybe I
should have just gone here anyway this
would have been smart to do before but I
didn't do that
oh you're faster too oh you're you're
much fat no please please please please
please please please please no no now is
not the time what do you mean now is not
the time am I supposed to kill let's say
all right fine let's do this [ __ ]
hey what's over this watch where you
what Oh see you all right yep Oh
fascinating
interesting you seem confused what where
are you going
what are you doing area what now ah
Oh missed
[Music]
Rick what the hell what the hell's wrong
with this thing is it dead no it's not
that it just heals oh now is not the
time what now after I'd really really
really really I'll take that thank you
really thank you really appreciate that
really really really really appreciate
that that guy sucks
oh man wish I had my shotgun well just
wasted a bunch of explosivo rounds on
that guy who whatever okay you win some
lose some
now did I leave an item up there I bet I
did okay what's in here
well let's i like bullets is this whole
area count as one area or they're
subsections so i don't see any other
items up here
alright see you around buddy serious
I won't see you around oh no no no oh
are you not shooting where you where you
stop circling you did I'm out of ammo
didn't think I'd be in this situation
but here i am here i okay I guess I'll
go nowhere who's doing that why find
them have it your way
oh hey well this is awkward
interesting listen I'm just gonna I
don't really have the bullets to deal
with you right now so I'm just gonna you
can't dodge him that's just dumb this
dumb dumb dumb that you can't do that
wait a dead end no way okay
did I get everything I have no idea I
might be missing items but at this point
does it really matter I don't know okay
combine you with you command you put
there but there yes good and what does
this but Oh fancy but what about the
stairs what if I just took the stairs up
isn't the stairs did I just close off my
iPad I did I just did all right you wait
there Nikolai oh this is the bedroom oh
sorry not my stop not myself not myself
not my stop oddly enough not my stop oh
wait I can trick them oh wait no I can't
not if I do that well turns out that is
not how you do that not how you do that
okay here more bullets
that's good ideally save something so
that way back there would go back
towards the room I was at before which
would be handy-dandy up please thank you
perfect Fleur fect almost died great
gunpowder that's good
ladder wherever this goes
is this where I'm supposed to be your
own
I do not have the ammo for anything
walking out of there oh I'm not ready
for that
oh no oh hey you're fine I thought it
was gonna be something actually
dangerous
Oh oh okay all right I'm gonna quickly
why did they have a container full of
those things that's the question of the
day right there
all right screw the mag I'm gonna
combine just for show D goñi ammo
because that's what I like and that's
what i'ma get I do I have another black
one more popping out of there well yep
there it is
okay oh god no I'm not ready for you
please tell me that killed it okay did
not
[Music]
that killed it no it did not kill it
okay please tell me those something else
in here that I can get to shoot it with
no it's just an herb I'll shoot you with
the nerve baby come here you boy we did
miss me oh my god oh my god oh my god
I'm gonna climb climb climb climb climb
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay so I would be
able to get back and get my shotgun from
this office if I go through here but I
think I can lead them over here and go
around how you doing bud nope I marry
you oh they don't want to if I die it's
probably gonna set me back a long ways
that's okay I think I'm okay I think I'm
okay
I think I'm okay just go here unlock
this go through this door these guys
don't like to go through doors for some
reason and I'm safe I don't know maybe
bring out the shotgun uh let's bring out
the shotgun oh my god I have so many
shotgun shells hell yeah what's my hell
that fine actually surprisingly fine
I've got plenty of explosives that I
could make for flame rounds which would
be decent acid rounds I could make maybe
acid rounds would be the things that
would actually kill those regenerating
guys I don't know for that for certain
I'm gonna go with shotgun for now I
don't know why I'm like so hesitant to
actually use the resources I have this
is the thing about me with the games
when they give me like a limited
resource
I am so unbelievably hesitant to use it
I never I like never want to actually
use it and I don't know why that is I
think what I need to do is woo there was
something in there there's gotta be
another item
to get in this area ah there's a door to
the right okay just in here there's a
door to the right oh boy that's not good
you hate to see that hey buds hi I could
use those shotgun shells it's just a
party in here or what the deal uh-huh
really that's fascinating that's really
fascinating guys oh my god yeah I
expected that to put you down but it did
not what good that's the door I need to
get to thank you thank you you punch
weirdos why is Wang as weird stop being
weird don't be weird
what I told you about being weird don't
do it don't do the weird you weirdos Wow
holy crap I was not ready for that
oh my god if you do a dodge with any
weapon in the name after oh it's gaming
after okay let me try the knife again
what what what
what just happened what the hell just
happened
hey dudes Oh get out of my way I did
dodged that vote so there is there oh I
killed two of them oh oh they were lined
up perfectly Oh perfect okay yeah I'm
away I don't know why that killed me
with that dude but baby maybe since I
got the show D gonna sell a shells maybe
maybe I shouldn't uh hello bud
oh you were there there you go yeah
maybe I should just shoot you
knife is cool but also it takes a lot of
time and energy no way I could do that
right here guys all right here goes
apparently my friend back rent whoa
sorry got slammed on the doorway all
right so I got all those let's put that
away for now good good good good good
good good you good I think that might
have been a bug of like cuz I was not at
low health so I shouldn't have died from
one hit like that I think those bugs
like slamming up against the wall and it
like got me scooched and just decided to
kill me as opposed to anything else why
is this still red I'm gonna give a quick
once-over
oh god I forgot about you oh god no no
no god dammit no no no oh god no god no
okay good good no no do not do that you
[ __ ] you guys suck
okay is there something around here that
I've missed oh I see I see it I see it I
see it okay there was a reason why you
dropped that elevator there is a reason
I see it I see it I see it there is a
reason it's right there in the case I
don't know if there's gonna be anything
good in the case but that's gotta be the
thing that I'm missing Oh
oh my god it was so worth it it was so
worth it oh my god I don't even know
what that does probably makes faster
reload increase me yeah baby yeah baby
yeah baby yeah baby okay so I don't need
to go back through that guy although
apparently maybe I do because they don't
have any health items hey bud hey bud
hey bud hey bud don't come back you suck
so much ass you suck the most ass
I can't dodge those things so those
things are undoubtable it's just
impossible to dodge all right combined
use and then I'm gonna make another just
because I had all this stored stuff and
then I just lost it like a whole I think
you guys are gonna be pleasantly
surprised I am going to take out my
grenade launcher and I'm going to number
one make explosives but I'm also going
to make acid rounds
because I'm curious of what they would
do you know what I mean I don't know for
sure and I'm gonna save them but it
seems interesting I have opened my eyes
and I'm gonna use it I'm not gonna be
the person that just doesn't use
something just because
I don't have I'm gonna put my gun away
for now just because I don't have
bullets show my is well not I've got
plenty of mine rounds should I bring
those out
I'll bling the flame rounds yeah this
one's good let's do this
I've got acid rounds I'll save it for a
boss probably but it might be
approaching if some county boss here I'm
just gonna go ahead and blast you oh
[ __ ] that didn't get him to help how's
this not getting him just died oh my god
out tough are you [ __ ] how weak is
this explosion okay now they're done
let's go forward I'm just gonna sprint
sprint sprint sprint sprint sprint
sprint sprint sprint no no no no no no
no that none of that no no no no no that
none of that pop in Nikolaj I've got a
present for you it's a loud one Oh
Nikolai you could have been behind me
and shoot me in the back the head no I
don't know man what is he doing
apparently I didn't even need to kill
those guys I could have just run on by
but I didn't so I guess egg on my face
oh well I guess I haven't you I wasn't
using the mag but I'll take the mag all
so is there something here what do we
have your unfinished activity log 1,300
infiltrated RC disturbances or sporadic
commencing mission observe five our PD
officers engaging a pack 20 strong
officers annihilated in 20 minutes
test run at University diverted pack
including canines to campus 64%
infection and conversion in two hours no
survivors successful rendezvous with MV
platoon will make first attempt at dawn
diverted packed word command post result
Oh what the what
[Music]
what happened I was reading that Joe
tell you well I got through it they're
willing to negotiate they'll call off
the strike gift and this is one big as
if we can deliver the vaccine to them
before they launch how long do we have
hours maybe then let's not waste one
more sight
yeah too bad someone else is going for
it right all right I was reading that
why did it stop all right let me go back
to the files I want to finish that
female JV has made Oh Jill Valentine
maybe has made contact with MV platoon
bioweapons appearance and behavior
consistent with project end
investigating observed a bio weapon
wielding conventional weapons it seems
to be strongly fixated on terminating
Jill Valentine and knows the city layout
evidence it can be imprinted
metamorphosis in the bio weapon
triggered by a hostile encounter with
Jill Valentine video attached Jill
Valentine has been infected in his
non-responsive collected samples per
orders over seventeen hundreds have
elapsed since Jill Valentine's exposure
to virus conversion has been slowed
suggesting she may be resistant vaccine
recovered and administered to Jill
Valentine by Big E a soldier in MV
platoon Jill Valentine expected to be
fit for combat approximately twenty
hours post exposure it seems clear that
bio weapon is project n contact with JV
causes it to change and evolve will
induce further encounters to obtain more
precise data this Nikolay doesn't seem
to be everything the Nikolay appears
unless it's Tyrell nuts it's gotta be
nikolai definitely probably nikolai boom
baby i don't know what that did but it
looks beefy whoa look at that
Oh reduces recoil increases the guns
destructive power I don't know how you
manage to do that but ok fine by me I
guess I'll use it loaded E
you'll find a vaccine up ahead will we
are you sure about that
or did we not get the vaccine Oh maybe
it was the original sample of the virus
itself maybe it wasn't the vaccine maybe
I'm being crazy I can't run this is
cinematic this story sure you don't need
to stop stop and do what I got your back
uh yeah let's get this done you got my
back all right you got my back as in you
gonna get my back you're gonna get my
back
[Music]
you think I grabbed my good weapons
Oh Andy well poor Tyrell oh no have I
seen this in resident evil the movie the
lasers favor barely hi oh you're not
decontaminated that's no good that's not
decontaminated either this whole place
is contaminated oh hello oh no there's
contaminations in those oh no earlier
contaminated nest to employee
regulations the objective of this
t-virus research facility different from
those of umbrellas main nest facility
here we focus on real-world use cases
which arise as new bioweapons are
created and introduced such as the need
for t-virus vaccines and new weaponry
capable of suppressing bioweapons some
aspects of our work here can be
dangerous so it is imperative that all
employees adhere to workplace
regulations without fail in particular
unauthorized entry by an appropriate
unapproved visitors or but the removal
of work late data in materials will be
met with severe disciplinary measures
such as death or shooting in the head it
is a great honor to be a part of the
finest research organization in the
world keeping this in mind and stick to
the rules as we forge new and
revolutionary technologies and Abeka
zombies I got a matter oh my god this
place big oh this place big oh this
place real big that's good to know that
this place big I need more bullets I
need a lot more bullets I'm gonna peek
my head of rule yeah I get more bullets
yes please
okay I'm gonna peek my head around the
corner see what's up say howdy do
oh don't trust that but I don't have the
bullet to waste on it then again I could
probably could say that I didn't have
the bullets to waste on anything before
you zombie ah no way I know a zombie
when I see one
and you ain't a zombie no way I see
high-grade gunpowder though I love that
if I cared about the mag ammo I would
use it for that but I care a lot more
about the shotgun so I'm gonna save it
for that gun ammo I don't really need
that at the moment you're just filling
in my inventory but that's okay I'll be
back at the safe room momentarily
there's more stuff in here I don't know
why I'm on edge I just for some reason
I'm expecting something to jump out at
me at literally any moment is biggie
down here somewhere good thing I'm a
expert in biology essay on vaccine
senses oh it's all explained there I
could read it in two minutes I'll know
everything I need on the roles of
antigens and adjuvants Nathaniel Bart
okay to most efficiently synthesize a
vaccine both the antigen and the
adjuvant are required the antigen
produces an immune response while the
adjuvant increases the effects of such
responses leading to increased antibody
production by combining samples of these
ingredients one can create a potent
vaccine base by processing this vaccine
base with our proprietary equipment a
larger batch of the vaccine can be
created with astonishing ease what's
more my latest antigen and angevine
samples yield unprecedented rates of
antibody production producing more than
a thousand times the yield of
traditional materials this not only
makes it an effective vaccine but also a
potential way to eliminate existing
infections interesting that's why it
worked you know if this guy actually
focused on making you know vaccines for
the world to stay healthy methinks it
may be he could do some good but no
chooses to make bioweapons yeah what are
we here okay ooh I don't know what
you're about what's the deal with you no
but I'll probably need you to override
some things
oh you look big oh what's in there what
is in there got a box with the women in
it okay how do I get to that okay I got
to get to the incubation lab oh I got to
go through no I'm not gonna be able to
get that damn it damn it and damn you
Dan all of you damn all of you straight
to hell uh huh what did you say about a
key some sort of super special override
key is that what you're talking about
ah boy turns out you were just waiting
for me to shoot you in the brain yeah
well maybe not the brains okay
definitely down for the count
looks suspecious somehow I knew it right
in the ass you say that that works too
if you have here Isaac graves diary the
pay was generous the benefits were good
most importantly they promised me I'd be
contributing to state-of-the-art medical
tech research for university teachers
stuck working in nowhere America was a
golden opportunity like winning the
lottery so I went for I made the pitch
to my family and we agreed to move here
to Raccoon City huh hindsight is 20/20
because this lab is a den of monsters
who conduct cruel and barbaric
experiments for the sole purpose of
taking human life in the most sickening
way possible it's messed up the world
needs to know but every time I work up
enough courage to blow the whistle
I think of petit and Casey and
immediately chickened out umbrella owns
this town there was this guy that caught
trying to smuggle out company secrets
they essentially fed him to one of the
beta's fed him I saw the whole thing
I got my wife and daughter into this I
just need to do my job
because I'm told for their sake but let
this be a testament that I do have a
conscious and that I learned my lesson
well wait you didn't do anything I mean
I guess yeah it's it's a rough situation
to be in and what do you do are you
gonna do with your family like that but
yeah I guess what can you do
Oh keep your override key the key that I
got my override key the ovary key not
ovary key the override key Ovation P key
of override nation I'm gonna bring you
out the last bit of gunpowder I got and
I'm gonna put you there and then I'm
gonna pop a save and I'm gonna say thank
you everybody so much for watching this
is a lot of fun I've been having a great
time with this it is just a delightful
gift an honest-to-goodness delightful
game I feel like we're getting close to
a conclusion but I don't know because I
have a funny feeling of the thing the
secret ending the true ending is gonna
be hidden behind a hardcore playthrough
so I may have to play through the whole
game again oh no I have to play a game
that I enjoy again oh gosh darn it Noel
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always see you
[Music]